you see designers who seem to dominate
the ux UI design world creating stunning
apps and websites that attract thousands
of likes and admiration it feels like
they have a special talent for Designing
things their users instantly love right
the truth is you just don't know what
they know no one has shown you the cheat
codes the secrets that the top 1% of
designers know but you don't however
everything is about to change today
you're going to level up you will learn
a few powerful UI design tips through
practical real life examples that will
show you how to design and think like a
senior uxui designer it's time to go
from a junior or beginner uxui designer
and join the top 1% of designers so if
you're ready to take your design game to
the next level keep watching all right
here's the scenario imagine you're
designing a sleep tracking app your goal
is to collect daily data on how many
hours to use her let's call her Emily
slept last night you also want to assign
a quality rating such as great good
neutral poor or bad based on the number
of hours to help Emily understand how
her sleep duration relates to Sleep
Quality sounds simple enough right let's
look at how a typical Junior designer
might approach this but here's the kind
of design you might see from someone
just starting out clean straightforward
navigation check big title at the top
that says how long would you say you
slept yesterday check below that we've
got five options Emily can choose from
ranging from great to bad each linked to
a specific number of sleep hours these
selections are made with radio buttons
and the selected state is highlighted in
the app's primary color now at first
glance you might be thinking hey this
works and sure it's it does the job it's
functional it's clean and the design is
easy to follow but hold on let's think
about it is this the kind of app that's
going to Delight Emily and keep her
engaged every single day does it make
her feel something or is it just another
simple data entry task does this design
accurately represent the goal of helping
Emily understand how her sleep duration
affects her overall quality of rest I
think we know the answer to that now
let's take a look at how a slightly more
experienced designer would approach this
design how about something like this
this already looks much better right
let's understand why first let's talk
about the title we've made two important
changes here
personalization we added hi Emily to
personalize The Experience people
respond more positively when they feel
recognized and even something as simple
as using their name can enhance
engagement clarity and simplicity we
revised the title to how long did you
sleep last night users prefer language
that is conversational and easy to
process and this phrasing feels natural
reducing friction in the interaction now
let's talk about how we reorganized the
layout in the previous version the state
labels great good and bad were more
prominent than the actual hours slept
but here we've shifted the emphasis to
the hours this follows the principle of
visual hierarchy where the most critical
information the hours is given more
prominence the state labels still
provide useful feedback but they are
secondary this ensures that users focus
on inputting the correct number of hours
first before reflecting on the quality
the radio buttons are now placed on the
left side this aligns with the F pattern
in natural reading order which users are
accustomed to by placing the interaction
controls on the left we ensure use can
quickly and intuitively make their
selection without unnecessary eye
movement or cognitive load we've added
emojis next to each sleep option to make
the experience more fun and relatable
instead of just numbers and words the
Emojis bring a bit of personality to the
app making it easier for users to
connect emotionally with their choices
the Emojis also visually reinforce the
idea that more sleep leads to better
outcomes for example a happy Emoji is
tied to longer sleep while an upset
Emoji is linked to Shorter durations
this makes it easy for users to
instantly understand what each option
represents encouraging healthier sleep
habits in a way that feels natural and
engaging we've also made the selected
State much more distinct by changing the
text color and making the Emoji larger
for the selected option we're adding
system feedback good feedback lets users
know their input has been registered and
provides a satisfying resp responsive
interaction all right this design was a
step up from the first one but we're not
done yet let's take it to the next level
and create an interface that feels not
only functional but also fun and
intuitive to interact with how about
something like this instead of a basic
list we now have a curved slider that
makes the experience more fun and
engaging it feels less like filling out
a form and more like a journey letting
Emily slide through her options in a
natural satisfying way Emily can swipe
between sleep options making the
experience more intuitive and satisfying
than clicking a button swiping feels
natural on mobile devices making the
interaction smoother and more mobile
friendly the selected option is now
entered and enlarged making it clear
which sleep duration Emily has chosen
the size contrast guides her Focus
reducing confusion the large emoji and
bold text give immediate feedback is
this the only other option no it's not
let's look at something different to
make it feel even more personal for
Emily what about this design in this
version the selected state is now front
and center right in the middle making it
the most prominent part of the screen
this isn't just a small detail it's an
essential part of the design when Emily
selects an option it's highlighted
visually with the larger emoji that
gives immediate feedback the Emoji in
the middle not only shills Emily
selection but it also reinforces her
choice with positive feedback whether
her sleep was good or something else
this centralized feedback combined with
encouraging text like your sleep was
good aimed for 8 hours for the best rest
makes the experience more motivational
and informative for Emily as Emily
selects different options both the Emoji
and the feedback change dynamically this
adds an element of fun and
personalization the app isn't just
collect data it's giving realtime
responses that help Emily understand her
sleep patterns better now let me show
you one more option for Designing this
experience in this design the selected
Emoji stays right in the middle giving
Emily immediate visual feedback about
how well she slept but this time we've
taken it up a notch by adding a slider
below the Emoji making the experience
more interactive for Emily as Emily
slides through the Sleep durations the
Emoji and feedback text dynamically
change in real time creating a more
engaging experience for instance here
she can see that she slept 2 hours more
than the night before which adds a layer
of personalization and helps Emily feel
more connected to her progress this type
of interaction brings Emily closer to
her sleep data making it feel more like
a personal Journey rather than just a
task compare this to the previous design
I think this version takes interaction
to the next level now I want to make
this video a bit more interactive for
you too pause the video and tell me in
the comments which design I designed you
like the most and add a reason why do
you prefer option A for its clean and
simple design is option b more your
style with its Dynamic swipeable
interaction maybe you like option C for
its Emoji selection and encouraging
feedback or does option D stand out with
its interactive slider and sleep
comparison I'm really curious to hear
which one stands out to you and why
write it in the comments I've got even
more tips for you in this video but as
you've seen so far even small tweaks can
turn a good design into a great one the
reality is becoming a great designer
takes years of learning and even then
you might still be missing some key
elements to consistently create
beautiful designs that's exactly why we
created the UI ux Playbook a
comprehensive guide packed with over 100
actionable tips principles and
strategies that can take your designs to
the next level and save you many years
of frustration and failures The Playbook
has received five-star reviews from more
than 10,000 people who have already
downloaded the free preview or grab the
full version don't miss out on this
opportunity to learn how to create
beautiful designs yourself just click
the link in the description to get your
copy and if you stay until the end I'll
give you a special gift now let's shift
gears and take a look at the world of
Finance picture something like this
you've designed a stunning banking app
with a clean modern interface that users
love imagine the possibilities when your
app not only looks great but also offers
a seamless user experience you can find
the full tutorial for creating this
beautiful banking app design including
the source files in our ux UI design
Mastery course now imagine you need to
design payment experience a flow where
users can easily transfer money to their
friends Michaela Jenny and Rachel so
let's get back to our home on our mobile
app and click on at the bottom to go to
the transfer screen to see how an
average Junior designer would design it
we have a basic layout with two buttons
and redundant text it's a simple design
that you can say in a way works but
let's see how a more senior designer
would design this experience this is
much better now let's compare this to a
design from a junior designer instead of
cluttering the screen with unnecessary
text or multiple options we've used the
space more efficiently we added a recent
recipient section along with the search
bar by doing this we eliminated the need
for a separate choose from history
button and streamlined it to just one
clear call to action this design Choice
does a few key things it lets users see
people they've recently transferred
money to making the process faster and
more intuitive it reduces interaction
cost a key the UI design principle
you'll learn about in our UI ux Playbook
every unnecessary action you remove from
the process improves the user experience
this senior level design not only looks
cleaner but it also leverages important
ux principles to create a more seamless
and userfriendly experience so let's
dive deeper into the transaction process
now imagine your app supports
transferring funds in different
currencies here's how a junior designer
might approach design of the transfer
screen there are two separate Fields one
for selecting the currency and another
for entering the transfer amount this
layout works and technically it gets the
job done but it's not optimized for the
user's experience now let's see how I
would improve this what about this this
instantly feels better first you need to
think from the users's perspective
what's the most important task they want
to complete entering the transfer amount
so I've made this the focus of the
screen making it larger and more
prominent to immediately draw the user's
attention on the other hand selecting
the currency is a secondary action the
currency selector is tucked neatly into
the corner of the amount input field
making it available but not distracting
this assumes the user will most likely
transfer money in the same currency most
of the time so the emphasis remains on
the amount this minimizes distractions
and keeps the interface Focus focused on
the task at hand now let's take it a
step further and enhance the user
experience even more how would you do
that I would do it by giving users a
clear visual cue of who they're sending
money to incorporating a profile photo
or even just an icon next to the
recipient's name an account number does
more than just personalize the
transaction it Taps into the principle
of recognition over recall instead of
having to remember specific details like
account numbers users can quickly
recognize familiar faces or icons making
the process more intuitive and reliable
this subtle addition helps users feel
confident that they're sending money to
the right person reducing the risk of
accidental transfers now we can take
this a step further by adding your new
balance section directly after the
transfer amount this addition gives
users instant feedback on how the
transaction will affect their account
balance so not only does it allow them
to see their current balance but it also
shows what their New Balance will be
after the transaction is complete this
improves transparency and helps users
feel more in control of their finances
minimizing any surprises after sending
money sadly you will find that many
banking apps miss this feature now let's
imagine the user has multiple accounts
perhaps a business account a personal
account or even a joint account in this
scenario it's important to clearly show
which account the payment is coming from
to avoid any confusion we can Implement
a simple yet effective solution
displaying both the sender account and
the recipient's account prominently
during the transaction this ensures the
user knows exactly which account will be
deducted whether it's their personal
business or joint account by doing this
we give the user a clear overview of
their accounts and reduce the chance of
Errors they can easily switch between
accounts before finalizing the
transaction making the process both
intuitive and flexible you can really
see the big difference in how a Junior
and senior designer would approach the
same experience as a senior uxui
designer Your Role goes beyond just
creating visually appealing designs you
have a deep understanding of your target
audience their needs frustrations and
motivations you step into their shoes
considering the environment and context
in which they'll use your product by
doing this you don't just design
interfaces you craft intuitive user
centered experiences that solve real
problems and make interaction seamless
now let's move on to the final tip offer
selection instead of manual input
imagine your designing an onboarding
screen for your product and you want to
ask the user for their job title here's
how an average designer might handle
this this design has a text field where
the user has to manually type in their
answer while it gets the job done it's
not the best approach why because it
requires more effort from the user and
introduces the possibility of tyos
inconsistent responses or frustration
with thinking of the right title now
let's see how a senior uxui designer
would handle this instead of a manual
input field I would add a selection of
the most common job titles users can
simply tap their role making the process
faster and easier I also brought in some
personality by incorporating icons next
to each option for those whose job title
wasn't listed we included another option
allowing them to either input their own
title or select it as a general option
when designing you can play with
different layouts to add more visual
appeal But ultimately you always have to
prioritize the user experience we put a
lot of effort into creating this video
and it would mean the world to us if you
could support it by sharing or leaving a
comment and because you you stayed until
the end I have a special offer for you
use code awesome 50 to get 50% off on
either our Playbook or the design
Mastery course thank you for watching
and I wish you a beautiful day